I don't even know how to sum up our previous segment,
but Denise has been sleeping in her living room
for 10 years now, so that Waverley could have her own room,
and I'm so excited to show them and reveal
their new living room.
So, you ready?
Yeah.
All, right, let's do this, here we go, come on.
Open her up.
(Crowd cheering)
(applause)
Oh my God.
It's awesome.
Totally different, right?
It's fabulous!
Yes, that's what we wanted to hear.
I can't even believe it.
Wow.
It's so beautiful.
I noticed that the colors-
It's like a real living room.
I noticed that you really lightened
and brightened it up, Mikel, too.
You know what?
I felt like it was kind of cave-like, right?
Kinda, kinda.
Yeah, so we wanted to lighten it up,
obviously, with the walls that we're looking at right here.
Wanted to keep it neutral, but then I wanted to give you
a little punch of color.
So Drew, I think you'll recognize this wallpaper
that we have right here.
That's right, I made that wallpaper.
Wow.
Yeah, so that's one of those things, I think,
that really elevates the space, but you know what the best
part about this entire room, we created it
in less than $1000.
Unbelievable.
$1000.
And let me show you how.
Honestly, the biggest thing is thrifting.
We all know that thrifting and repurposing
is the best way to get the most bang for your buck.
For instance, this couch right here, less than $300.
Let me say, as a matter of fact, Drew, sit on this,
I just want you to touch this thing.
This is vegan leather.
So, how does it feel?
So awesome.
So much better.
In terms of storage, I know Drew is a huge fan
on storage.
Everything has to double.
Yes, yes.
So, unlike your other coffee table,
now this coffee table actually lifts up
so you can put all the TV remotes, all of the blankets.
You can get everything.
Yes, the clutter.
Yes.
How do you close it, Mikel?
Do you know?
So, they have a little mechanism lock here
and then this just goes down once we unlatch it.
Now, another thing when we talk about storage,
look over here now, you have all of this storage
and organization.
The biggest thing was using that vertical space.
Now we have lots of shelves, lots of baskets
and that gives you that opportunity to hide
all of that clutter.
And now everything looks purposeful.
And I think that's the biggest thing right now,
making it functional and purposeful all at the same time.
Fabulous.
I also love that you chose to do a workspace
because with homework and the school and, you know, work,
this way, you have a functional space where
you can sit, but also get things done.
I love that you went with the romantic florals, Mikel.
I think that's really beautiful.
There are just pops of flowers.
It softens it up a little bit.
Absolutely.
It's also just the neutral color palette that you chose
as opposed to the dark, the sort of browns and navys.
Those were the tones I was getting
and this feels much fresher.
Yes, and lighter.
And speaking of light, did you see your two new lights?
So now, you have overhead lighting here.
And then additionally, we have your task lamp,
which is over to the right that I found at the thrift shop.
So it's perfect just to kind of brighten the space up
even more so.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
One tip I have also, if you're ordering online
is a lot of sites, including Cherished will have a filter
bar and you go under it and you do within 25 miles,
which you know that you can pick up very easily
or they're not gonna charge you for shipping.
You can even do within 50 miles if that makes sense to you,
and you totally avoid the shipping costs.
And you know you can just go pick it up.
It's as if it's in a store nearby you,
and that can eradicate hundreds of dollars and delays.
So that's a really helpful tip when you're filtering
through these vintage sites.
I just can't thank you enough, Mikel,
for brightening up the space freshening it up.
No problem.
I could never
have done this.
Thank you, Mikel.
Thank you so much, Denise and Waverley,
I love you so much, it hurts!
I'm so glad you ladies like it.
Love it, it's fabulous.
(upbeat music)